o Olá a todos pessoal daqui quem fala é
o Dark sejam muito bem vindos a mais um
vídeo e hoje trago-vos aqui esta coisa
que eu fiz na minha cabeça já pintei o
cabelo não sei o que é que Tu fizeste o
teu cabelo Porque que tu perguntaste ele
estava tão mais bonito antes Sabes o que
é isto Olha a pensar para mim mesmo vá
que faz qualquer coisa tem que mudar a
muita coisa que eu posso mudar que é por
mais vídeos você não quis me dar o que é
que eu podia mudar mais arranjar um cão
não isso é cara eles estavam Boo é
também podia mudar muita coisa mas não
precisa pintar o cabelo e por que que eu
pintei de azul inicialmente eu ia pintar
de branco mas tipo não cabelo preto para
branco é difícil a segunda opção foi
pintar de roxo algo vocês vão ver um
vídeo a seguir mas rosto era aquele a
curva me devolver aos para tipo duas
semanas e já vão ficar enjoado por isso
não a terceira opção era pintar de
vermelho mas depois eu pensei em é
melhor não porque depois vocês dizem que
eu sou a copiaram Ai tipo Ai auxilie na
não vermelho não qual é a cor que falta
Qual é a cor que a minha namorada por
acaso também não sei azul eu vou estar
aqui dentro da segunda é sempre entre e
vai bota e pronto pintei de azul que foi
assim que aconteceu mas isso não é
aquele Sul podres é tipo Azul como viram
e dinheiro tá bué fixe Eu gosto mas eu
tenho usado assim muito chapéu porque
tipo eu não estou habituado a ver assim
se eu não vir ao espelho eu só vou ver
essa parte azul e pronto começa a
habituar assim aos pouquinhos depois
começa usar assim depois começa a usar
assim sempre mostrar um pouco mais um
azul e depois a câncer o chapéu fica
assim pronto agora já sabem pessoal como
vocês viram deficiente na rua com o
cabelo azul é o Dark sou eu E agora já
vocês vão ver um blog foi quando eu fui
ao cabeleireiro pintar o cabelo Desde já
muito obrigado ao cabeleireiro era uma
vez em Cascais só se for em dessa zona
passem por lá tipo se quiserem fazer um
corte Pintar alguma coisa eles estão
tipo brutais cinco estrela não sei se
site Neste vídeo a um anúncio
Samsung assunto é daqui e tudo o que é
bom é para ser anunciado por isso é link
está na descrição pois temos todos que
Facebook Instagram tudo é isso espero
que vocês gostem deste blog é usado
muita curtinho tem tipo um minuto e tal
10 minutos eu acho que o que está
Engraçado que é isso pessoal tanto que o
nosso like e Favorito Neste vídeo eu
disse que era crescente E ai
meu Deus eu dar que eu dar que não
em primeiro lugar penteei-me
[Música]
estou sempre
antes de pintar o cabelo todo eu decidi
pintar só um pouquinho só para ver como
é que ficava e foi por isso que ele é
esta técnica esta coisa azul eu
descolorante que vocês têm que por antes
de pintar e estar para não
mentira só um pouco Sim isto parece um
gente eu sei olha aí já estou ficar
loiro e
E aí
Bom dia agora que já tem o esparguete na
cabeça e vamos pintar de roxo ó tá ficou
há algum tempo depois Vejam só pessoal
um rosto ficou no meu cabelo que quer
dizer que eu posso descolorir ao todo a
cor vai pegar
eu aqui assistente para porque
ele começou a ficar verde mas é normal
porque ele vou que o descolorante por
cima do roxo e agora vamos pintar de
azul
estar que merda de cabelo só por
isso vale a casa de banho
Vejam Só tá a ficar roça e
o
rapaz all day with
our own
as notícias são fixas